Shalom aleichem.
Oh Mr.
wrong language,
isn't it?
I hope nobody heard that.
You guys.
This is another one of those videos that
I filmed for my Japanese channel a
couple of years ago,
so I will be speaking in Japanese in
this video,
but don't worry.
I made English subtitles for you.
It just might seem kind of strange that
I will be talking about the Arabic
language in Japanese.
Kind of weird.
But what can you do?
I didn't want to remake the whole darn
video,
so check it out the way it is.
I hope you like it.
Go.
We'll let you out.
Day goes.
I must to either one.
Sweet Day,
unless she must have done it will not
go.
Goes open or sweet status old gang goes
up your bonus.
I'll be a little while.
So go your desk to toto.
Africa tube.
Ego could go toe to toe with adobe or
going to Hogan.
Zim,
Bu Fukumoto native speaker.
Need Ten huci opening.
Good.
He must.
That'd be overlap.
You don't get going until you get.
He will similar and had been.
Dia has 100 filler shots were in favelas
in,
but I go to God and have the son of God.
Was the Kashi.
More sort of more.
I know you've got one tiny tugging gold
generis each or not.
How could in your debt,
so got google glass,
paneled it to do clinical data.
Ek Dickie named by a bus you've got in
La and you're homeland,
not holguin,
Yadi.
Savoy caught another.
So we'll actually go by.
You're not good.
You got your dog and after that we'll
come into good title nasal,
but some of it you are yours.
You can go there.
Somebody must not a good in my stuff,
so not caught on to your vehicle while
your jungle.
You'd only mushed up.
You might not have that up so they can't
get in day.
No,
I don't give that up.
So I'm on the corner and we're going to
talk about on the show that you're
seeing that again to a dead end course.
Acid at the Naples,
seeing that shit a bit timid it.
Then he got one day,
not Monday.
One day more origin and actually my
sense of you who are not your gym go up,
boom,
market is not only more vulgar,
day dyno gamed up as up,
boom,
boom.
Goto gene gun killed.
You can go there,
so go ahead.
If we should get in country,
she's in the country code.
I know.
Boom,
go there.
Our mccosh and all that didn't go there
and I stood on the day so they can't go
out.
And the hunger that Chi Washington to
time for sure it isn't.
I'm no cute or the morning I'd be a good
guy shoot until until I Africa to kindle
that he must have done it again and I
said to keep their dun dun boom.
Got Cut on cocaine.
One hundred and two key mashed up.
Dakota bank,
your dorm.
Not.
I'll be sort of one more day.
Have you gone this cushy job?
She's in a key authentic unitus to
cooney.
Not Hogan or she couldn't,
you know,
so Gnh booking or you can work magic
man.
He Been Knight.
Not retain that up.
Say it up.
You can go a bank.
You're sort of out sourced it up.
Key Honda.
What come up short?
I need Hogan Bank.
Your startup number.
Hook got up,
plug in that I asked another up.
He thought wnl Cooney,
Niki Taylor.
That your course data that it's good to
tighten that up.
Sort of.
I couldn't,
you know,
Holguin.
Thank you everybody.
So my whole game duck in Georgia and go,
I've a bunch of many bank your she needs
or more organic by quarter where your
google to do a desk at all.
You don't talk and I'm going to call
you.
Y'all go up and I'll be auto generated.
This digital learning must sort of cut
off and get on death row or no alphabet
today.
People aren't going to be turning need.
I don't go up leaky gut up Monday.
Cockiness sort of.
What was it?
Gosh.
Sword in all.
I'm going to come by my center Monday.
Then the issue come up.
You should come with a cup of northern
shoes that are more dynamic module to
Muscogee more day.
What people.
They will meet a need.
Okay,
tonight is on that.
You want me to quit?
She,
she'll,
she caught the ball boy in an eight hour
day on the show and I'll be able to know
you caught them on parties.
Need another.
Caught the ball and be dead dog,
bowie souls or the credit union at it.
I've got a one day.
They're not gonna do it.
Yeah.
And then they'll cut to Bacara.
How'd you mean my short guy might have
a.
my mom don't you emit the show.
Might have our hello Meta Madhava.
Okay.
I might have a good job.
You're going to give us that nice.
Very nice Jitsu up.
Someone called about our total cargo.
No,
I sat on any.
Tended toward a quick little day.
Middle Hubba,
Hubba go up.
Jumped up.
We're gonna.
Need.
Ako said that you tend to call the
borrower.
That's good night.
Good Old Jack Ski.
And uh,
it's me,
Paul.
And Hi.
It's me,
my name and uh,
it's me and it's me.
Go ahead.
Yes.
And you're Kentucky master.
Nice.
All right.
After he talked to one more mean Aina,
enter doesn't see it.
Don't mean enter.
Enter.
What?
I'm not doing me this drop the
tendonitis.
Nintedanib untitled.
And not that,
I mean I know meanwhile from to emit
able then from sort of can't homebody
cut up mean Aina?
I ain't know what Doco sort of got a
body.
Where do you,
I mean under from.
Were you listening?
I mean I know you were gay.
I mean I know sort of.
What does it say?
How much did it took?
Any Joel say door?
Any.
I mean,
I know auntie under well don't say it
unti.
Well Joel said me neither until.
I mean I know Auntie.
What?
Okay.
I mean I know Auntie very nice.
All right,
good job.
So do you want.
I know I do give you this net on the men
or what to do.
Meanwhile from Jamie.
This name on the men Canada.
I know Canada.
I'm not the whole digital.
Double your that one to go on.
Amen.
I on a men Canada.
I'm not that well,
but you once you go.
All right,
you'll get it shorter.
I'd be a good unity.
Mushed up your book off.
Shoot them all.
I'm not to cut off.
Okay.
I mean I not under meaning on top.
All right,
very good.
On a men that are sort of,
I say guidance your Kentucky much the
I'll be able to.
Sure.
Good.
I got enough done it.
Plus you're going to be much more
natural.
Gas.
Can.